wann haben sie liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
zum letzten mal gespielt und sind sie dazu zu
einem priester in den beichtstuhl gegangen oder
fühlen sie sich mit ihren schuldgefühlen auf der
couch des psychiaters besser aufgehoben warum
genügt es nicht gott oder dem eigenen gewissen
gegenüber direkt rechenschaft abzulegen mit
meinen beiden gästen spreche ich heute über
schuld vergebung untreue herzlich willkommen ob
gewann federer vorsteher des klosters einsiedeln
und daniel strassberg psychoanalytiker und
philosoph turban in vorbereitung auf dieses
gespräch habe ich mit zahlreichen katholikinnen
und katholiken gesprochen männern und frauen alten
und jungen nur sehr wenige haben mir positive
erlebnisse erzählt wie war das bei ihnen als
ich zum ersten mal zur beichte gegangen sind das
allererste mal so genau kann ich mich dann nicht
mehr erinnern aber die ersten male was ich war
sicher sehr nervös denn es ging um etwas anderes
es ging um dinge wie gehe ich mit meinen eltern
mit meinen geschwistern also das erzähle ich ja
normalerweise nicht so auf der straße ich war
sehr nervös und auf der anderen seite darf ich
sagen es war etwas für mich positives was ich
habe hier nie schlechte erfahrungen gemacht
sondern durfte einfach da wieder raus gehen und
das war's lange straßberg sie stammen aus einer
jüdischen familie sind in zürich aufgewachsen
haben die öffentlichen schulen besucht und kamen
sich auch mit katholischen kindern in kontakt
waren sie neidisch als sie merkten dass die zur
beichte gehen durften oder dachten sie gott sei
dank brauche ich nicht zu gehen weder noch mein
bester freund in der primarschule war katholik
und der musste jede woche ich glaube es war
mittwochnachmittag unfall nachmittag in die kirche
beichten gehen und ich ging in meistens begleiten
und das merkwürdige daran ist dass ich das gefühl
hatte eine sünde zu begehen dass ich überhaupt
eine kirche betrete war obwohl ich glaube meine
eltern nie gesagt haben ich dürfe keine kirche
betrete aber ich hatte das gefühl dass ihnen
der einer übertretung umfang das ungeheuer
spannend dass während wien die sünden vergeben
wurden wie ich eine beginn das ist interessant
und sprechen gleich noch darüber wie das judentum
auch vielleicht mit der frage der sündenvergebung
umgehen wird zunächst einmal möchte ich aber gerne
wissen viele katholikinnen und katholiken die ich
befragt haben nach ihrer ersten beichte die sagten
mir praktisch unisono sie hätten eigentlich gar
nicht gewusst was sie hätten berichten sollen
dass sie hatten gar kein verständnis gar kein
schuldbewusstsein in diesem alter und viele haben
ja auch gesagt sie hätten daraufhin dinge sogar
erfunden also sie haben eine lüge begangen um
dann in die beichte zu gehen können dann eine
sündenvergebung zu erlangen was für eine schöne
begriff kann ein 78 9 jähriges kind haben wenn
ich am kinder bräuchten denke das gibt es bei uns
in der innerschweiz so im verein vorbereitung auf
die erstkommunion heute noch das wird heute ja
genau da bin ich eigentlich erstaunt wie groß die
sensibilität von kindern ist für was gut und nicht
gut gut und böse ist ich staune eigentlich dass
kinder das bereich zu können weil ich bin auch
immer davon ausgegangen was die mir dann sagen ist
ja wahrscheinlich nicht das was ich sagen würde
würde ich aber heute nicht mehr so sagen aber
kinder die eine sünde in der beichte bekennen ich
denke jetzt mal dass sie vielleicht gegenüber den
eltern ungehorsam waren dass sie nicht ordentlich
waren dass sie vielleicht in der schule vermittelt
haben irgend einer weise dass ich nicht nett
verhalten haben ist das was die katholische
kirche als sünde bezeichnet oder könnte man nicht
sagen das sind tugenden unschöne ereignisse aber
ist das wirklich eine sünde also ich denke mir
die beichte begleitet ja auch ein veganes menschen
und sowie das gewissen von jungen menschen auch
gewendet wird durch sozialverhalten also durch
durch den alltag wird das in der beichte auf eine
religiöse stufe gehoben das auch von der religion
her das gewissen gebildet wird da muss aber jetzt
nicht jede und jeder einen mord begehen damit er
dann zur beichte kann also ich denke mir da
geht es einfach darum sich immer wieder die
frage zu stellen wie gehe ich mit meinem leben
wie gehe ich mit meiner freiheit um auch wenn
ihr mit diesen begriffen dann nicht immer so
operieren können sie das als psychoanalytiker
nachvollziehen dass im alter zwischen sieben
und neun eine derartige auseinandersetzung
mit den eigenen unzulänglichkeiten mit eigenen
fehlerhaftigkeit stattfinden soll das findet
natürlich auf jeden fall statt also das braucht es
die weichen dazu nicht die kinder lernen wie sie
sich verhalten sollen unternehmen und die erste
art wie man das lernt ist durch den liebesentzug
der älteren denen man befürchtet wenn man
etwas schlechtes gemacht hat also das erste
sozialverhalten wird durch angst vermittelt man
hat angst dass eine strafe kommt und schlimmsten
fall der liebesentzug und daran lernt man was
man ob das dann schon gut und böse ist das weiß
ich nicht aber man lernt wie man sich verhalten
sollen und was mit der band passiert ist eine
ein schritt der ob der altersadäquat ist oder
nicht dass das kann ich nicht beurteilen aber
es kommt die zeit in dem ich dieses vorab schauen
dass von der eltern internalisieren muss also ich
muss irgendwann lernen mich nach mir selber zu
beurteilen und nicht nach der reaktion der eltern
mir scheint 7 nach etwas früh zu sein aber es
ist zu einem übergang zu einer von der reinen
externen verhaltens regulation zu einer internen
verhaltensregeln aktion indem man es nicht ganz
mit sich selber macht sondern noch jemanden
der bei hat der mich einen darüber spricht also
insofern finde ich das nicht völlig abwegig nein
und brauchten denn oder brauchen auch heute die
kinder in irgendeiner form vielleicht nicht gerade
liebesentzug aber doch in irgendeiner weise strafe
zu befürchten wenn sie ihre beichte ablegen
in form von gemüse etwa die das setting einer
beichte ist ja ein religiöses das kann man nicht
vergleichen mit einer couch wie sie das einleitend
gesagt haben obwohl es wahrscheinlich auch nicht
mehr so stattfindet das heißt da hat ja auch das
wort gott oder das sprechen über gott platz und
wenn ich jetzt mit einem kind zum beispiel eine
geschichte anschaue im beispiel von gott dann
werde ich nicht zuerst mit dem wort buße kommen
sondern vielleicht mit den barmherzigen vater oder
mit dem vater der dich liebt und möchte dass du
weiter auf deinem weg gehst durch die beichte den
kindern auch ein positives gottesbild genau genau
und von sich selbst was auffällt ist dass früher
ein zwang eine pflicht zur beichte bestanden hat
man ging wöchentlich oder monatlich zur beichte
wird entweder von den eltern geschickt oder auch
die kirche die da eine gewisse kontrolle ausübt
heute wenn ich auf ihrer homepage von ihrem
kloster in einsiedeln nach sehr dann wird das als
ein angebot formuliert vom zwang zum angebot wie
ist das zu verstehen gut ganz vergleichen kann es
miteinander nicht weil wir sind ein wallfahrtsort
wir sind keine pfarrei und was sie vorher erwähnt
haben sind das was früher frei aus sozialen druck
da war das war ja nicht nur bei der beichte
also wenn der metzger sein fleisch wirklich
verkaufen wollte musste er zur kirche sonst sind
die leute nicht mehr zu ihm gekommen weil da geht
dir nicht in die kirche und das ist war ja nicht
also das ganze hatte mehr mit druck zu tun ein
wallfahrtsort ist eine möglichkeit aus dem alltag
auszutreten wir haben wenn es auch viele leute die
gehen über einsiedel nach santiago di compostela
die machen aus einen weg von bis zu drei monaten
und wollen dann da irgend ich sage es bewusst
auch einen stein abladen vom herzen die nämlich
tatsächlich zum teil auch steine mit also das ist
eine besondere situation wo man sich denkt wenn
ich schon mal in einsiedeln binden könnte ich
doch reichten also nicht ganz vergleichbar mit
leichten die auch angebot werden in den üblichen
anderen verein ich hoffe inhaltlich schon aber
einfach das kann ein wallfahrtsort das angebot
also da ist war immer so bei niemand musste in
einzigen leichten gehen werden sonst verliert
er soziale druck in ein dorf auch in einer stadt
schon da war komme den heutigen mehr leute zu
ihnen nach 1 sind unser beichte als früher wie
entwickelt sich das nein ich denke sind weniger
die beiden kinder verlängert also früher kamen
massen an leuten die nach einzigen kamen heute
sind es zum teil auch gruppen die das zum teil
als angebots dabei haben dann kommen sie alle
sie kommen aber auch aus einzel pilgerinnen und
pilger und wollen dann aber auch nicht irgendwie
abgespiesen werden mit mit 23 minuten sondern das
was ich auch ein gespräch entwickeln können hängt
dass leute die schon länger nicht mehr gebeichtet
haben oder vielleicht zum ersten mal kommen es
geht alles es gibt jene die regelmäßig beichten
gehen und dann nach einsiedeln kommen und das
gefühl haben es tut mir gut hier ich hatte auch
schon leute die mir gesagt haben ich bin nach
40 jahren das ist immer halt wieder in einem
fahrstuhl es gibt auch leute die dann sagen bitte
helfen sie mir ich habe keine ahnung wie das geht
ich war noch nie der beichte und das kommt häufig
vor etwa auch weil leute kommen die vielleicht gar
keine christliche religionsunterricht haben gibt
es heute auch es gekommen auch so weich und das
bereitet ihnen keine schwierigkeiten die beichte
eine sphinx abzunehmen eines muslims eines juden
also grundsätzlich kommen die menschen nicht
für die beichte sollten die war echt ist für
die menschen da also wenn mir jemand entgegenkommt
versuche ich aus dieser situation etwas zu machen
damit dann den konkreten menschen geholfen dass
ich ihm dann aber nicht eine bibelstelle vorleser
oder ihr nicht die absolution gebe im namen des
dreifaltigen gottes ist dann für mich eigentlich
schon eine selbstverständlichkeit denn ich bin
ja nicht darum die leute zu überfahren sondern
sie haben irgendein anliegen und das muss ernst
genommen werden was machen sie mit menschen die
kommen und sagen ich möchte meine gedanken
meine belastungen hier vielleicht abladen
aber ich bin völlig ungläubig verstehen ich
atheist ich auch ob die dann immer gehört in
den weg in den wald stattfinden also es gibt
ja warum es noch ganz andere anlaufstellen
die kommen vielleicht in die kirche und wo
er mit einem mönch sprechen und sagen dann
am anfang also ich bin gar nicht gläubig aber
das interessiert mich oder die melden sich via
internet im beichtstuhl drin sind dann die leute
eigentlich schon mit irgendeiner sehnsucht das
mit schuld umgegangen wird es war den religiösen
eine einem einer redaktionskolleginnen hat wird
sich gerade den selbstversuch gemacht und ist ins
kloster gekommen und hat so eine beichte abgelegt
und man kann ihren erfahrungsbericht online auf
unserer kultur platt platz plattform nachlesen
deine straßberg ist es für sie nachvollziehbar
dass menschen heute mit einem trotz einer
säkularen angebots und trotz kirchlicher
distanz liebe leute heute zum teil haben
trotzdem den weg in die kirche finden um eine
weiche abzulehnen was ist das ein grundbedürfnis
des menschen und die beichte abzulegen
das werk ein grundbedürfnis zu sein aber
eine sehr nachvollziehbare reaktion aber es ist
ein grundbedürfnis mit schuldgefühlen zu einem
anderen menschen zugehen und diesem mitzuteilen
ich bin immer mit diesen grundbedürfnissen sehr
vorsichtig ich glaube diese vorstellung von
beichte schuldbekenntnis und so weiter ist eine
relativ neue vorstellung ich glaube das musste
man muss einen historischen zusammenhang sehen zum
beispiel im judentum gibt es die vorstellung der
barig der auch das sündenbekenntnis es eigentlich
nicht es ist entschuldigung die ausdrucksweise
ist völlig wurscht was sie denken es ist wichtig
was sie tun aber sie haben doch im judentum auch
die gesetzestreue die verlangt und den menschen
und wenn man ein gesetzesbruch begeht dann ist
das auch ein vergehen gegenüber gott wickelt
dann die jüdische mensch mit dieser situation um
ja da kommt der begriff der zu war zwar kann man
übersetzen rückkehrer aber kann man übersetzen mit
antwort dass beides selbe wort und damit um indem
er das nicht mehr tun als kreative wenn er einen
schaden angerichtet hat er den schaden wieder gut
macht punkt das ist alles das ist also eine sehr
weltliche betrachtungsweise es könnte nicht und
der unterschied zwischen weltlicher und und um
nicht weg sondern um den unterschied zwischen
die innenwelt und außenwelt die vorstellung
ein beichte ist dann die vorstellung einer
innenwelt gebunden oder anders gesagt das
ist dann die vorstellung gebunden dass es
wichtig ist was für intentionen in jemand hat
und nicht ganz so wichtig was er wirklich tot
und diese vorstellung der seele als innenwelt
die seele die intentionen hat die motivationen
hat und dass diese motivation wichtig sind die
ist eigentlich am anfang der moderne gebäude
gibt es als pflicht seit 1215 vor gab es das
nicht und ich glaube dass die beichte ein ganz
wichtiges instrument war in der kulturgeschichte
zu installation der innenwelt dass man kann ja
sagen zur installation des gewissens das gab es
vorher gab es damals bevor die leichte eingeführt
wurde schon so etwas wie das was ich heute
ja auch anbieten zusätzlich seelsorgerische
gespräche ich bin ja nichts sonst werde ich
nicht so schwarz hier das mönchtum beginnt
eigentlich in der ägyptischen wüste und
da kann man schon nachlesen wie frauen und
männer in die wüste rausgehen um diese mönche
und auch nonnen aufzusuchen und mit ihnen ihr
eigenes leben anzuschauen wir nennen das heute
geistliche begleitung übrigens ganz interessant
wir haben noch viele aussprüche dieser ersten
wüsten seite und die werden sie oft so an den
anfang von psychotherapie hergestellt weil das
zum teil ist nicht einfach eine unterscheidung
zwischen weltliche und religiöse sondern die
auch etwas zu sagen haben über das psychische
wohlbefinden eines menschen also das sind schon
die kaum ist sich die christenverfolgung fertig
beginnt eigentlich dieses hingehen zu mönchen und
nonnen um das eigene leben mit ihnen anzuschauen
diese tradition kommt als griechen tun nicht
aus dem judentum dieses anschauen des eigenen
lebens das ist eigentlich etwas was die juden
nicht wahnsinnig interessiert aber es gibt auch
thema wie soll ich legen wie soll ich handeln
also diese exerziert ja zum beispiel marc aurel
schreibt dass man immer am abend aufschreiben
muss was man den tag durchgemacht hat um sich
rechenschaft über das was man getan hat also
letztlich doch die moralische bewertung des
guten ganzen handels aber nur des handelns nicht
des gefühls also die schlechten und guten gedanken
die schlechten und guten motivationen die
heute im zentrum stehen die gab es damals
noch nicht machen wir noch einen schritt weg
von den innenleben gehen wir noch mal zurück
zu den äußeren was ja auch auffällt ist und sie
hatten wir das eigentlich im vorgespräch auch
schon angetönt dass das beichten etwas ist dass es
nur in der katholischen römisch-katholischen und
in der orthodoxen christenheit gibt obwohl martin
luther nicht beabsichtigt die leicht abzuschaffen
warum ist die beichte bei den reformierten heute
nicht zuzutrauen vieles was wir heute als typisch
reformiert und typisch katholisch anschauen kann
man nicht unmittelbar auf die zeit der reformation
zurückführen sondern auf die zeit danach und
man sich abgegrenzt hat wo man gesagt hat also
weil du im gottesdienst deutsch spricht werden
wir nur noch lateinisch und zu sagen wir sind
dann die und umgekehrt das martin luther zum teil
noch bis fast täglich zur beichte ging als es ihm
schlecht ging das ist heute weniger bekannt nicht
übrigens dass er keine kritik an der praxis der
damaligen zeit gehabt hätte das war sogar sein
haupt gab es eine seine hauptkritik punktgenau
aber er hat damit nicht die beichte abgeschafft
dass das abschaffen von gewissen tradition die
dann einfach wirklich zum stillstand kommen hat
sehr viel mit der zeit danach zu tun ich habe
einen für mich verblüffend dass die tat gefunden
von martin luther dass er angeblich in seinem
großen pazifismus geschrieben haben soll ich
zitiere willst du es aber verachten so stolz ohne
beichte hingehen so fällen wir das urteil dass du
kein christ ist also keine beichte kein christ r
starten sie das würden sie das unterschreiben ich
muss ein solches zitat natürlich immer in seinem
uhr kontext jetzt müssen wir die ganze stelle
lesen verstehen denn so könnte ich das jetzt
nicht sagen also auch martin luther könnte ich
mir vorstellen würde heute einem lutheranischen
gläubigen nicht sagen du bist kein christmas
keine christin wenn du nicht gehst ich glaube
hier geht es ihm wirklich vor dem sein vor gott
und er hat das in der beichte so erfahren dass man
dort in diese freiheit kommt frei in christus
wie es paulus sagen würde aber wie gesagt er
müsse man ist das ganze anschauen und bleiben wir
mal bei der frage der schuld wenn wir den ersten
schritt der beichte betrachten so ist dass die das
bekennen das formulieren dass verbalisieren von
schuld und da werden sie kann ich einfach stehen
also den bekennen voraus geht ja die reflexion
da geht ja wirklich das das bewusstsein voraus
es gibt ja in ein grund warum die person kommt
das wäre dann die vorbereitung ja aber auch in
der beichte selber dass man wir beginnen mit
einem religiösen kontext dass wir machen auch
in der katholischen bereich der wirklich auch
das kreuzzeichen miteinander dass wir da nicht
irgendwie das gefühl haben wir sein irgendwo
sondern das eigentlich ein liturgischer akt der
hier geschieht und dass dann die person sagt
ich bin gekommen und dann bekennt was sie schon
versucht hat für sich vor der beichte aber doch
zu beginn der beichte zu überlegen es kann nämlich
auch sein dass ihn und sagt ich weiß ich weiß ich
muss hier her kommen aber ich weiß nicht genau
wie ich das sagen oder warum ich das sagen soll
oder was ich sagen soll da kann es möglich auch
sein dass es zu einem entwickeln eines gedanken
kommt aber der ausgangspunkt ist ein schuld- oder
schuldgefühle ja davon gehe ich aus im vorgespräch
mit ihnen daniel strassberg als ich sie nach der
schuld fragt aus psychoanalytischer sicht sagten
sie schuld sei aus der sicht der psychoanalyse
völlig uninteressant und ich glaube dort ist
auch der große unterschied zwischen beichte und
psychoanalyse obwohl das gerade modern ist oder
war eine sechziger jahren das zu vergleichen vor
allem durch michel foucault ich glaube die schuld
interessiert den priester und interessierten
psychoanalytiker nicht warum hat sich der
psychoanalytiker mit den schuldgefühlen befasst
kann man das voneinander trennen das muss man
voneinander trennen die h sie müssen hier vergeben
werden wie wenig schuld mit schuldgefühlen zu tun
haben wenn sie daran denken zum beispiel das
psychopathen ganz viel schuld auf sich laden
überhaupt keine schuldgefühle haben und sie oder
andererseits depressive menschen die ungeheuer
schuldgefühle haben ja keine ahnung weshalb
irgendwie habt caracas wenn sie gerade daran
denken dass besonders gute reflektierte menschen
viel schuldgefühle haben verbrecher keine oder
wenn sie daran denken dass leute mit wahnsinnig
viel schuldgefühlen ein grässlicher auf die nerven
gehen können und fordernd und unangenehm sein
können und überhaupt kein empfinden für schuld
hat sondern nur für schuldgefühle ich glaube es
gibt aber einen gewissen widerspruch zwischen
schuld und schuldgefühle der liegt darin dass
das real dass leute mit vielen schuldgefühlen
keine reale schuld kein reales schuldbewusstsein
haben kriegel verwirrten jetzt vielleicht sagen
die psychoanalyse versucht den menschen dar und
einzureden sie tragen keine schuld sei eigentlich
es gibt eigentlich keine schuld es gibt nun
das gefühl dass würden in ihren wagen ich würde
nur sagen wenn jetzt jemand kommt und ein mord
begangen hat und jetzt schuldgefühle hat und eine
psychoanalyse machen möchte da würde ich hatte
nicht so ein extremfall aber solche ähnliche fälle
habe ich und dann kann ich nur sagen sie haben zu
recht schuld gewesen da kann ich einfach nichts
dazu beitragen würden sie dann allenfalls einen
patienten an die kirche verweisen wie das täte
jung gemacht hat angesagt die polizei vorbei ist
und sagen also ich war der polizei stellen sonst
mache ich es nämlich nein ich würde eher sagen ich
hab dir nichts zu sagen könnten wir noch irgendwo
sagen dass sie ihre patientinnen und patienten zur
medienfreiheit in kontakt bringen möchten während
wir sie haben vorher von innenleben und moral
gesprochen versuchen dann zu zeigen wie könnte man
mit dieser freiheit umgehen natürlich von einem
christlichen kontext her sie sind die nehmen sich
natürlich auch wertneutral bei uns ist das ja so
bayern ja sie dürfen ja eigentlich nicht stellung
nehmen werden dich zum beispiel dann sagen kann
bei uns würde jesus so damit um gewinnen oder
höher hat so ein wort gesagt irgendwie so etwas
ich würde das etwas spezifizieren wollen das mit
der freiheit das ist nicht falsch aber man ist
ja etwas genauer sein wenn jemand zu mir kommt
mit schuldgefühlen da gibt es zwei möglichkeiten
das eine er sagt ich weiß gar nicht weshalb ich
die habe oder es gibt die zweite möglichkeit dass
er sagt ich habe es wegen in irgendeinem vergehen
von dem man das gefühl hat dass er vollkommen
inadäquat dass es schuldgefühle auslöst oder
zumindest in diesem maße auslässt was ich als
psychoanalytiker tue und das hat sehr wohl etwas
mit freiheit zu tun ist die schuldgefühle an ihren
platz zu tun es gibt eine sehr sehr schöne stelle
bei frau in seinem berühmten fall dem rat man der
ratten mann hatte ungeheure schuldgefühle und hat
von freud ihnen verlangt dass er ihn absolviere
so zu sehr hatten und freud hat dann geantwortet
wenn sie schuldgefühle haben dann haben sie sie
zu recht sie wissen nur noch nicht weshalb und da
kommt das unbewusste ins spiel also was wir tun
ist das schuldgefühl an den platz zu verweisen
wo es herkommt und dann und da haben sie völlig
recht dann ist eine freiheit im umgang möglich
solange ich nicht weiß woher die schuldgefühle
kommen kann ich nichts damit machen da habe ich
einfach während das wichtige unterschiede dass er
sagen können wer zu ihnen zur bekommt er bekennt
nur bewusste schuld viele sagen übrigens auch ich
bekenne auch die die mir nicht bewusst ist einfach
aus dem bewusstsein heraus dass ich wahrscheinlich
immer etwas tue was andere verletzen oder mich
selber verletzen kann oder dass ich mir dessen
bewusst bin dass das wird sehr oft auch gesagt
aber sie ergründen dann nicht woher diese dieses
verhalten kommt das zu schuldhaften verhalten
wiederum hielt ich glaube hier sind wieder im
sehr wichtigen punkt wo wir uns unterscheiden
müssen was ich bin ich habe vielleicht ein
paar psychologische kenntnisse mitbekommen
im studium aber ich bin nicht psychoanalytiker
es kann sein dass ich jemandem sage wissen sie
ich kann ihnen die lossprechung von gott her geben
aber sie müssten wenn sie das ernsthaft anschauen
möchten zu einem psychologen zu einem psychiater
je nachdem also da muss sich ja auch ein priester
dann ganz klar abgrenzen und nicht etwas tun
wollen was nicht in unsere kompetenz liegt was
ein weiterer glaube ich sehr zentraler unterschied
ist am ende der beichte steht ein verzeihen das
vermag psychoanalyse nicht wenn ich jetzt ganz
orthodox wäre also im orthodoxen nein nein das
kommt auf keinen fall vor ich verzeihe nicht
ich mache nur das unbewusste bewusst aber es ist
natürlich nicht zu bestreiten dass das ist dieses
moment des verzeihens in der psychoanalyse gibt
herr hat seiten dass ich aus die analytiker sage
das ist nicht so schlimm oder machen sie sich da
kein kopf raus oder dass diese entlastungsfunktion
der psychoanalyse zwar in diesem orthodoxen sinne
des reinen bewusst machen nicht vorkommen dürfte
aber natürlich unser alltag ist also das ist was
dann wieder verbinden wer also bei ihnen suchen
die leute in der beichte eine erleichterung eine
heilung vielleicht auch irgendwo und bei ihnen
suchen sie auf heilung sie gehen ja zu ihnen zu
einem arzt muss vielleicht ein bisschen schwarz
weiß zu sagen sie korrigieren nicht wenn ich das
haus schwarz weiß sage bei ihnen ist eigentlich
das ziel dass sie wieder zurücktreten denn der
mensch selber weiß jetzt wie zb etwas orientieren
kann während ich bewusst dann am schluss gott im
mittelpunkt stelle und sage von gott her wird
hierfür ziehen also ich nehme mich da in dem sie
nicht zurück das war übrigens der konflikt
zwischen freud und jung das hat freut dann
jung vorgeworfen sie sind pfarrerssohn sie wollen
immer den leuten sagen was sie tun sollen ich bin
analytiker ich analysiere nur das war ein großer
streitpunkt zwischen beiden hat dass er auf dem
pfarrerssohn zurückgeführt eine gemeinsamkeit die
mir auch auffällt ist bei beiden handelt es sich
um ritualisierte gespräch sie haben einen festen
ablauf und der beichte ich mir mal jemand kommt
haben sie auch einen festen ablauf aber ein
unterschied ist ihnen muss ich wahrscheinlich
häufiger kommen bei ihnen ist es mit einem mal
erledigt und es ist europa kommt noch dazu mit
eimern erledigt ich selber gehe nicht nur einmal
in meinem leben also ich versuche unterwegs zu
sein unterwegs auf gott hin man muss vielleicht
historisch betrachtet sagen das eigentliche wir
nehmen das bei unserer katholischen tradition
nach produkten wie einen das sakrament das
eigentliche sakramente taufe und das haben die
menschen aus erwachsene erhalten und haben dann
gesagt das ist für mich eine umkehr eine umkehr
zu diesem neuen leben in christus und dass man
gemerkt hat der mensch hat die besten absichten
und vorsätzen und geht dann doch auch wieder wege
wo er sie am anfang gesagt hat man denn möchte
ich hier nicht mehr gehen da kommt dann dieses
sakrament der versöhnung hinein dass man sagt ich
möchte mich da öfters auch wieder versöhnen mit
mir mit der kirche und mit gott und von dem hier
natürlich für das eine mal wenn du das spürst du
kommst raus und du bist dir ist vergeben dann
ist das ein sehr schönes gefühl das heißt aber
nicht dass du das nachher nicht wiederholen
kannst wir haben sogar bei ihm situation dass
man sagt für die großen feste also man fest zu
feiern möchte man eigentlich in reinen tisch
haben um dann wirklich feiern zu können und das
sind normalerweise ostern aus das größte fest des
christentums aber auch pfingsten weihnachten dass
man sich darauf vorbereitet durch die beichte das
ist an vielen orten noch gute tradition eine
weitere unterscheidung oder 1 1 eine weitere
andersartigkeit die mir bei der analyse in den
sinn kommen zwischen beichte und psychoanalyse ich
habe den eindruck wenn man zur beichte kommt dann
geht es darum dass der mensch sich demütig verhält
oder auch demütig wird durch die beichte weil
der psychoanalyse habe ich den eindruck es geht
genau um das gegenteil es geht um das heben des
selbst wertes um vielleicht auch ein bisschen das
meeren des egos ich glaube das ist ein missbrauch
der psychoanalyse als religion und treffen also
ich glaube es kommt auch bei mir von einem gar
nicht mehr in den sinn kommt da macht man heben
des selbstbewusstseins das gibt das wirkt immer
sagen das ist nicht aber das haben die psychologie
ist eigentlich nichts zu tun denn es geht darum
verbindungen her bewusst zu machen reflexionen
zu machen die einem wie abt urban gesagt hat in
die freiheit führen und dieses dieses gesülze
dass ich immer wieder von der psychoanalyse höre
dieses heben das selbstbewusstsein halte ich für
verfehlt was fangen sie den mitteln bekämpft
der demut an als psychoanalytiker das ist
einfach ein begriff der in psychoanalyse nicht
folk also das ist ein wesensfremd begriff das
hat etwas so viel zu tun mit der psychoanalyse
weder begriff motor oder benzin und wenn ich
sie als philosoph frage bin ich wieder philosoph
frage würde ich sagen das und da können sie mich
aber auch als psychoanalytiker fragen es gibt
ein bewusstseinsprozess in der psychoanalyse
der manchmal nach vernachlässigt werden dass es
darum geht die eigenen abhängigkeiten zu erkennen
was sie vorher angesprochen haben ist die eigene
abhängigkeit nur zu unterbrechen oder abzuschaffen
und ich glaube es gibt diesen prozess dass man mit
der zeit erkennt dass man eben nicht unabhängig
ist wie man gemeint hat es gibt ein ganz wichtiges
beispiel aber das kennen die meisten von uns wenn
man älter werden in den spiegel schaut man ja aus
wie sein eigener vater und dann ging ich weiß wie
es bei den frauen habe ich noch nie gehört damit
meine meinung ist das eindeutig so und dann erst
alle erschrecken und das hat genau damit zu tun
man meint man sei wahnsinn in bewegung geworden
und unabhängig geworden ein eigenes leben und am
schluss deswegen ist man dasselbe was vorher mal
hergekommen ist und ich glaube dieses prozess das
bewusstsein der eigenen geht dann könnte man einem
religiösen kontext de mut demut religiös leider
ist ein negativ behaftet weil ich glaube auch
viel unfug getrieben wurde man hat leute damit
gedemütigt aber demut ist für mich ein positiver
begriff familie aus dem lateinischen hat mit humus
zu tun also jemand steht mit beiden füßen auf der
erde leben auf der erde und religiös gesagt möchte
nicht selber gott spielen also man weiß im bereich
aber auch ausserhalb der beichte in der demut
dass man einen auftrag hat eine verantwortung
dass man dem nicht immer entspricht das man aber
auch jetzt nicht abheben muss um zu sagen ich weiß
alles besser und wenn es nach mir geht ist die
welt gerettet da bin ich eigentlich froh um demut
und ich möchte noch für viele leute die in dieser
welt verantwortung haben wünschen dass sie mir den
mut haben und wirklich auch in der verantwortung
für die welt für ihre völker handeln und nicht
nur noch einigen eigenen machtstreben gehen wir
über zu einem anderen thema als psychotherapeut
und auch als beicht abnehmer befinden sie sich
unter umständen beide in delikaten situationen
insbesondere sie hatten es schon angesprochen
wenn sie konfrontiert werden oder kenntnis nehmen
müssen dass strafrechtliche delikte geschehen
sind sie sind dann an die arztgeheimnis gebunden
sie sind an ein beichtgeheimnis gebunden und wir
schauen uns jetzt eine filmszene an die dieses
beichtgeheimnis und auch den gewissenskonflikt den
dieses weist kleines auslösen kann eindrücklich
darstellt er findet sich in dem film icon
fest von alfred hitchcock aus dem jahre 1953
ich will beichten gott dem allmächtigen und ihnen
priester dass ich gesündigt haben wann
haben sie das letzte mal gebeichtet ich
kann mich nicht entsinnen können sie es mir
nicht annähernd sagen ich habe mist getötet
weiter
ich bin eigentlich sein haus gegangen ich war die
bestehe nicht erkennt ich wollte die polizei ruft
urban das dilemma des priesters ich möchte
ihnen an dieser stelle einige heikle fragen
stellen und ich möchte sie gerne an einem
hypothetischen fall festmachen angenommen
jemand aus ihrer klösterlichen gemeinschaft
kommt zu ihnen und beichtet ihnen sexuelle
missbrauch an kindern was sagen sie dann was
tun sie was raten die wie reagieren sie als
beichtvater diesen konstruierten fall kann man
sehr gut vergleichen mit dem was wir jetzt bei
hitchcock gesehen haben der in siegburg liebe
ich nach wie vor aber genau solche dinge nicht
passieren gibt es im kirchenrecht natürlich
auch bestimmungen was einen mord kann ich
nicht einfach sagen ich kann ich die jungs mal
gehört dass billig nicht einfach los und sage g
weil in einem kloster ist dafür geschaut dass ein
mönch nicht bei seinem eigenen abweichen kann das
genau nicht solche abhängigkeitsverhältnisse
entstehen seien sie positiver oder negativer
art also der könnte gar nicht zu mir kommen
und unter dem bett was sagen wo ich nachher
gar nicht handeln kann sondern ich bin als obere
das weiß er natürlich verpflichtet solche dinge
ernst anzuschauen auch eine meldung zu geben
und dann die konsequenzen zu ziehen und dass
das eben nicht so einer situation kommt dafür dass
gesorgt sind sie dazu auch verpflichtet wenn eine
priesterliche person aus einer anderen verein
jetzt nicht zu ihrer klösterlichen gemeinschaft
gehört zu einer beichte ablegen würde bei mir
weil ich nein da bin ich nicht verpflichtet weil
und nun werden sie in diesem moment konnte bei der
beichte haben sie immer die möglichkeit zu sagen
ich bin hier nicht kompetent in diehlo sprechen
zu gehen vor allem nicht wenn sie mir nicht die
möglichkeit geben dass wir das ausserhalb der
beichte anschauen also da muss man eigentlich
jemanden darauf verpflichten mit dem strafrecht
ich habe mir vorher gehört das ist im fall des
mordes gebracht dass man das auch strafrechtlich
anschaut das geht nicht einfach das ich so mache
und die leute gerne daraus also habe ich sie
richtig verstanden sie könnten in diesem moment
oder würden in diesem moment die beichte gar
nicht abnehmen und keine absolution erteilen
wenn ja in einem ersten fall ja lange straßberg
es ist ja auch denkbar und wahrscheinlich haben
sie oder möglicherweise haben sie schon solche
situationen erlebt dass auch zu ihnen menschen in
die sprechstunde kommen und erkenntnisse abliefern
die strafrechtlicher natur sinn wenn jemand jetzt
auch mit pädosexuellen neigungen kommt oder
gewalt zu gewalt neigt wie wir müssen sie sich
dann verhalten was tun sie was tun sie als arzt
was müssen sie tun in einem strafrechtlichen sinn
unterschied aber von pädophilen neigungen
oder pädophile handlungen ich glaube eine
ganz wichtige voraussetzung des psychoanalytikers
ist dass er nichts von patienten will das heißt
dass er nicht in einer irgendetwas eine richtung
dass er auch nicht für sich wegen dass er aus für
die therapie zu machen nicht wählen und es gibt
situationen da will ich etwas also ich will dass
er das nicht mehr tut ich glaube ich könnte einen
solchen menschen nicht behandelt ich habe eine
situation gehabt aber ein patient auf der flucht
von keefe das war die einzige heikle situation
in meinem leben hatte sie ein patient von auf der
flucht von gefängnis zu mir kommen wollte und den
habe ich auch nicht mehr handelbar sein mandant
grund weil ich gedacht habe nur ein zeugen ist es
nicht zurück muss ins gefängnis also ich glaube in
solchen heiklen situationen bin ich als therapeut
überhaupt nicht in einer schwierigen situation
weil ich das einfach nicht kann suizidalität ist
auch so ein problem dort will ich dass er überlebt
das kann ich auch nicht psychoanalytisch behandeln
was machen sie dann reagiere ich einfach als
psychiater und mache eine einweisung oder beim
medikamente oder was auch immer dann erforderlich
ist aber ich arbeite nicht als psychoanalytiker
jetzt der fall dass wir etwas strafrechtlich
relevantes innerhalb einer therapie erzählt
oder den gab es noch nicht und die frage ist wenn
ich jetzt diese therapie verweigere und den muss
ich dann zur polizei gehen oder so und da gibt
es eigentlich relativ formalisierte verfahren
die ich dann ich kenne keinen auch nicht auswendig
aber die die mich dann von meinem eigenen gewissen
entlastet das würde ich dann der staat würde ich
muss ich glaube ich dem kantonsarzt anrufen und
den fragen was man da zu tun da würde ich mich
einfach nicht solche gewissenskonflikte begeben
sondern würden wir das tun was das gesetz
vorschreibt sie haben stichwort geliefert
darum habe ich vorher so zögerlich geantwortet
es geht ihnen auch gerade darum dass es leute
gibt ich hatte mal einen fall eines menschen der
pädophile neigungen ins gespräch gebracht hat und
das ist ja nicht dasselbe wie einen tatbestand
ausführen das heißt mit solchen leuten kannst du
natürlich die beichte fertig führen du kannst
sogar jemanden ermutigen die kann ich mit dem
im leben weitergehen käme aber das hat sich jetzt
auch noch nie einen tatbestand der strafrechtlich
dann auch verfolgt werden muss das ist etwas
ganz anderes okay gut verlassen wir mal dieses
thema ein anderes thema das schon angesprochen
hatte ist die tatsache dass ich glaube allein
das christliche verständnis mit priestern operiert
die sozusagen eine mitra figur sind zwischen den
normalen menschen und gott wir haben in der
bei station die situation dass es eigentlich
aus meiner sicht eine gewisse dreiecksbeziehung
ist auch viele katholikinnen und katholiken die
ich zur beichte befragt habe haben mir gesagt
eigentlich weiß ich nicht warum ich das einen
einem beichtvater einem priester erzählen soll
ich mache das direkt aus mitkommt warum braucht
es aus ihrem verständnis heraus diese mit einer
figur für mich gedacht es beides also das was
jetzt schild und das finde ich eigentlich auch
das normale ich bete in meinem bekommen das
gebiet zu bringen in jedem vaterunser bete ich
verzeihe mir wie auch ich anderen verzeihe oder
in der eucharistiefeier als in der messe das
ja auch seinen platz schon zu beginn der feier
dann die feier selber der mensch kann immer
um verzeihung bitten das schön finde ich und
das befreiende gerade für heutige menschen die
sich sehr oft selber überfordern so nämlich ist
wenigstens war ist das sakramentale los sprechen
das heißt gott bindet sich an ein wort das sagt
ich verzeihe dir dass du das hören darfst aus dem
mund eines anderen ich bin ja dann zwar in dieser
dreiecksbeziehung der mund aber eigentlich das
dann gott sagt es ist so du musst das nicht hier
erkämpfen das musst du dir nicht erarbeiten das
wird ihr zugesprochen dass wir nicht dann einfach
eine hochform sag ich einmal des verzeihens und
das nennen wir sakrament wie auch bei den anderen
sakramenten gott in einer gewissen situation des
lebens da steht und sein wort sagt almli mit die
den koran liest lese ich natürlich oft in meiner
heiligen schrift davon dass gott alpha scientist
und wenn ich das laut rezitieren so ist das aus
meiner sicht dasselbe wie wenn mir der priester
das sagt wenn ich das höre also dennoch die
frage warum braucht es diese mittler figur
können es nach schließlich habe ich glaube wir
haben noch einen ganz wichtigen unterschied ist
natürlich analyse der beichte nicht benannt
und der spielt in diesem fall eine sehr große
rolle die beichte war ursprünglich ein akt ein
vollzug und kein reflexion sagt also die beichte
selber ist sozusagen die beichte in dem ich es
ausspreche ist die beichte vollzogen und deshalb
gibt es die absolution wenn sie augustin lesen
sozusagen das grundmodell der konfessionen ist
dann ist das schreiben dieses buches dieser akt
der sich gott hinzugeben es geht dort gar nicht
so und die reflexion was bin ich für menschen
und dieser akt der reflexion selbst ist die
darbietung zu gott und oder russo 18 konnte so
das öffentlich dafür geradestehen ist schon der
verteilung sagt ist schon der akt der metamorphose
das lesen sie bei bayer gustin es ist der akt der
bereich der der die metamorphose ist und das
ist der unterschied zur zur psychoanalyse der
es dort geht es primär nicht um den akt der
psychoanalyse sondern um den reflexion wegen
dem bug pracht auch viel länger weil es nicht um
den akt geht psychoanalyse zu betreiben sondern
um einen reflexionsprozess in gang zu setzen und
für diesen akt der muss bezeugt werden das ist bei
uns oder er schreibt ein buch das bei august in
der er schreibt er auch ein buch dieser akt der
metamorphose muss bezeugt werden und diesen akt
um denen es ein bisschen runterzuholen auf einer
theoretischen zur praktischen ebene kann dann
auch der sein der ganzen konkreten die tränen
fließen lässt das heißt eine person die bei mir
in dem beispiel kommt ich nehme an wird vorher
schon gesagt haben gott verzeiht mir das was ich
da jetzt hineinbringen aber durch das sprechen
das laute aussprechen im namen gottes darf ich dir
diese für zeigen zu sprechen ich sehr oft für die
leute dann einfach das befreiende warum sie dann
vielleicht wieder in den meisten kommen das ist
für mich nachvollziehbar und dennoch es gibt ja
auch die schwierigen seiten dieses verhältnisses
dieses dreiecks verhältnisses und eines das
wir jetzt gerade sofort in den sinn kommt dass
ich als frage formulieren möchte war es in der
vergangenheit nicht oft so dass er die furcht
vor der reaktion des priesters oder die angst
vor einer gewissen buß aufgabe oder vielleicht
auch vor dem erpresst werden viel größer war des
gläubigen der zu dem priester kam als eigentlich
die furcht vor gott und das wäre dann wiederum
ein vergehen auch nach christlichem verständnis
wichtig also ich denke mir mit dass bei der schuld
wenn wir bei dieser frage sind sie mir etwas vom
in diensten des menschen also ich sage mal nicht
mal probe und die fragen um den glauben als auch
schulz frage es ist heute schon fast intime aus
wenn es um sexualität jetzt darüber spricht man
heute in der presse aber nicht die schuld und
wenn es um solch intime sache geht dann ist
natürlich auch der missbrauch groß das gilt für
den religionen das gilt für die psychoanalyse
überall wo du mit dem kontakt kommst musst du auch
als priester als psychoanalytiker genau wissen wo
du stehst denn eine solche situation darf nicht
missbraucht werden ob sie kann das heißt aber auch
also sie anerkennen auch die situation dass sie
beide in einem hierarchischen verhältnis stehen
sie zu ihren patienten sie zu den menschen die
zb kommt ja und ich würde ich weiß nämlich jeder
sehen aber ich würde dem nie sagen wir sind auf
augenhöhe ich glaube dass es in den 60er jahren
hat man immer davon gesprochen dass das immer
auf augenhöhe ist ist es aber nicht die leute
erwarten ja auch von mir als priester sie erwarten
von einem philosophen oder psychoanalytiker dass
der sich damit schon beschäftigt hat und dass
er da vielleicht auch ein wort geben kann oder
mindestens auch sagen kann ich kann hier nicht
helfen also das ist quasi beides experten sind
beide in diesem expertenstatus und wer zu ihnen
kommt sucht ihre kenntnis ihr wissen ja es gibt
von lala com ein sehr schöner ausdruck von suzuka
ich bin ein subjekt von dem der andere annimmt ich
wisse etwas ich habe das ist beschreibt diese
hierarchischen verhältnisse ich bin sozusagen
experte weil der andere mich in diesem moment
nicht durch ein bestimmtes wissen oder lernen
sondern er installierte in der psychoanalyse und
auch im beispiel ist das ja sogar vornehmlich
inszeniert mit dem liegen und dem sitzen also es
wird mir etwas verlieren ich weiß nicht ob sie das
er bei ihnen wäre es sinnvoll gott verlieren oder
auch von den menschen auch in den händen es wird
mir sozusagen unterstellt dieses expertenteams
und mit dem und wenn ich das zurückweisen und den
patienten sagen meinen nur ich habe auch keine
ahnung von gar nix dann enttäuscht ich ihn nur
glauben müssen es andere die sich muss diese ziel
eine wunderbare geschichte von cesare pavese ein
ein widerstandskämpfer der sich als priester
verkleidet in einem bergdorf ein des zweiten
weltkrieges und dann eben zum priester wird durch
die neue durch die leute gehen zu ihm zur biker
und er muss um sich zu verstecken das und er wird
zum priester weil die leute in zu christen machen
so macht nämlich die leute zum psychoanalytiker
die eigentliche expertin den eigentlichen experte
bleibt schon die person die kommt denn sie ist
ja für ihr leben aber kennt ihr leben oder ist
es am entdecken verantwortlich von mir erwartet
sie einfach aus einem priester dass ich von der
kirche her von der bibel her vom christentum her
etwas dazu sagen kann und am schluss dann auch
diese worte der vergebung spreche wenn man jetzt
so allgemein recherchiert muss man feststellen der
ruf der beichte ist nicht ein sehr guter mann es
wird oft mit dem thema des missbrauchs vielleicht
auch nicht aber ich denke beim thema beichte
da gehen die emotionen sehr schnell hoch noch
schneller als bei der psychoanalyse die anonymität
ist etwas das auch gerade schwierige situationen
herbei wird der fahrer wusste oftmals über das
ganze dorf bescheid konnte die dinge gegeneinander
oder die menschen noch gegeneinander ausspielen es
wurde mit angst theologen gearbeitet die menschen
wurden auf ihre schwachpunkte hin unter umständen
hin analysiert und das hat dann auch weiteren weg
bereitet natürlich für weiteren missbrauch an
welchem punkt steht heute die kirche wenn es um
die aufarbeitung und das selbstverständnis der
priesterschaft bei der weiche geht die kirche
gibt es natürlich in dem sinne nicht weil sie
weltweit mit sehr verschiedenen kulturen ist
also bleiben wären einmal bei uns im westen also
in der schweiz ich bin in der glücklichen lage
dass ich nach 1965 geboren bin also ich sehe
das glücklich an andere vielleicht nicht das
ist nach dem zweiten vatikanum uns ein neubeginn
gibt auch immer wieder chancen also sehr vieles
was ich höre von missbrauch der beichte im sinne
von angst machen von ver demütigen das bekomme
ich von älteren leuten mit das habe ich selbst
so nie erlebt und ich sehe mich natürlich heute
aus priester in der tradition mit der jetzt papst
franziskus ganz stark stark operiert indem er zum
beispiel dass ihre barmherzigkeit ausruft indem
ich natürlich auch nicht dann den leuten sage wir
müssten das ist buße und das brauchte sollten dass
ihm diese perspektive auch stelle und ganz stark
spüren der papst möchte das mit der gesamtkirche
aber jetzt gerade auch bei uns im schweizerischen
kontext dürfen wir das noch viel stärker betonen
es ist ein angebot der versöhnung ein angebot der
barmherzigkeit gottes werden wir noch einmal
konkret wenn ich mir als frau vorstellen zu
einem priester zu gehen und unter umständen
ein thema sie haben zum kult gesprochen die
an sich schon intim ist aber vielleicht auch
in erotischen sexuellen bereich intime dinge
mitzuteilen so bereitet mir das offen gestanden
solange es keine weibliche priesterschaft in
der römisch katholischen kirche geht werden die
frauen weiterhin dieser situation aus jetzt sein
und wahrscheinlich auch einem größeren risiko
des missbrauchs wie fangen sie die frauen die
eigentlich das bedürfnis grundsätzlich nach einer
leichteren seelsorgerlichen gespräch hätten aber
dass aus diesen strukturellen gründen eben nur
von männern geleistet gilt also ohne dass ich
jetzt da irgendwelche statistiken dabei hätte
aus meiner erfahrung habe ich das gefühl es
kommen mehr frauen als männer das möchte ich
einfach mal so dahingestellt haben denn dann
sehen wir ja schon bei der projekte situation
dass sehr viele frauen sehr viel intimes von
sich geben seelsorgerlich es gespräch an sich ist
in erster linie nicht an ein priester gebunden da
kann man auch zu einer frau gehen sei es einem
pastoralassistentin in einem lern frei sei es
zu einer nonne in einem kloster sie haben also
da schon sehr viele möglichkeiten von frau zu
frau zu sprechen was bleibt das ist richtig dass
sie wenn sie wenn es um die eigentliche beichte
geht dann sitzen sie aus frau von einem mann ich
traue mir jetzt einfach zu dass ich von mir aus
nicht eine unterscheidung mache ob ich eine frau
oder ein mann von mir habe sondern mit dem umgehen
was die person mir sagt ob ich so weit komme dass
die frau dann auch das vertrauen in mich hat das
ist noch mal eine andere frage ich muss aber sagen
dass ich da bis jetzt keine schlechten erfahrungen
gemacht habe weil ich ein mann bin gut gekommen
schon sehr schnell zum schluss und eine frage
die mich noch interessiert daniel straßberg heute
ist oft die rede davon dass in fernsehdiskussionen
oder in sogenannten reality shows leute sehr
gerne sehr offen aber auch teilweise hemmungslos
ihre innersten schuldbekenntnisse oder auch
intimitäten preisgeben wie beurteilen sie das aus
psychoanalytischer sicht hat das noch irgendetwas
damit zu tun dass diese leute einen leidensdruck
haben bei denen sie sachen loswerden wollen oder
bewegen wir uns da schon beim nazismus ich muss
grundsätzlich sagen dass ich mit solchen zeit
diagnosen wie sie das von heute beherrschen
meine grundsätzliche wir haben also ich also
heute wird sätze die so anfangen leute bei mir
ich glaube das gar nicht aus verschiedenen gründen
glaube ich dass diese zeit diagnose nicht stimmt
erstens sind alle realistisches inszeniert hat so
viel ich darf hierher offenbar ja ja die werden
dann instruiert weil sie was sie dann sagen
sollen was sie sagen müssen das hat mit der
realität genau so viel zu tun im mit im haus also
dass der realität produziert wird das ist eine
illusion die und zweitens gab es ist natürlich
überall freakshows also das ist ein menschliches
grundbedürfnis wenn irgendwo menschen bedürfnissen
irgendeinem zuzuschauen der ein freak ist und der
das macht dass ich mich ja nie getrauen würde
das zu machen also das ist etwa auf dem niveau
der dame ohne unterleib im zirkus und hat mit mit
schuldgefühlen und schuldbekenntnissen eigentlich
überhaupt nichts aber es hat vielleicht
eine schamlosigkeit zu tun nein das glaube
ich nicht immer mit schamlosigkeit weil man
sie gar nichts von sich preisgibt man es hat
soviel schamlosigkeit wie ein schauspieler auf der
bühne man weiß über diese menschen überhaupt nicht
nachher sondern es ist eine inszenierte realität
an der man pass als passiver zuschauer einen
gewissen genuss haben kann weil man sozusagen
etwas in stellvertretung sieht diese menschen sind
sind nicht harmlos wie irgendein anderer mensch
als eine person die eigentlich sonst nicht fern
schaut und ich da mal reinschauen frage ich mich
sogar aber dass in sie die medien fachfrau und
die nicht bezahlt werden dafür also in manchen
bestehe ich daran denke das hat aber nichts
mit preisgeben von inneren zu tun sollten mit
reagieren auf welche fragen die eben inszeniert
sind also ich frage mich manchmal ob die leute
nicht bezahlt wir sind dafür dass könnten uns
überlegen und sicher können uns auch überlegen was
das für unser vieh unserer gesellschaft bedeutet
dass wir vielleicht dazu ein eigenes uns solches
anzuschauen und wohin unser schamgefühl und shoot
verständnis sich hin entwickelt hat ich bedanke
mich bei ihnen beiden ganz herzlich für dieses
gespräch ob der urban federer und daniel
strassberg die bilder und nachrichten von
flüchtenden menschen aus afrika und dem vorderen
orient reißen nicht ab was können und müssen wir
tun in dieser situation flüchtlingen zu helfen
ist christenpflicht das sagte der jesuit peter
balazs er ist nächste woche hier zu gast
wenn man kollegen norbert bischofberger